for more information on tutoring or how
to support moofy university and the
production of more videos please visit
moof university com thank you and enjoy
so Adams with more than one electron are
referred to as many electron atoms
multi-electron atoms and poly electronic
atoms they all mean the same thing okay
pointed that they have more than just
one electron now if you recall the
orbital energies in the hydrogen atom so
long as the principal quantum number was
the same all of the orbitals at that
energy level had the same energy right
the 3s 3p 3d all the same energy the 2s
and the 2p had the same energy if I
showed the the 4s 4 p-4 d & 4 F they
would have all been at the same energy
level okay that's in the hydrogen atom
that that's a specific case if we're
talking about the electron configuration
which is something that we'll talk about
later of the ground state hydrogen atom
it just has an electron in the 1s
orbital like that and that's it but this
situation is entirely different in atoms
that have more plus 1 electron the
orbital energies and many electron atoms
are kind of like this we have the 1s
orbital and then is down here 2x over
old higher in energy the 2p orbital is
higher than that in energy then there's
the 3s orbital then there's the 3p
orbital then there's the 4s orbital and
then there's the 3d orbital that's a
little bit higher energy than the 4s
orbital so what's going on here the idea
here though is that it's not just the
principle quantum number that's
important in terms of determining the
energy level of that orbital okay
because otherwise it wouldn't you would
see the case where you saw in the
hydrogen atom where if you have the same
principle quantum number the same energy
level that's not the case so what's the
reason for this the reason for this is
this is due to to shielding and
effective nuclear charge
and so so basically what happens here is
that not only is the main she'll write
the the principal quantum number or elva
or n value excuse me related to energy
but the sub shell is related to energy
as well okay so we already know that as
n increases the energy of the orbital
increases but in addition to that as the
L value increases the energy increases
as well we see that here that's again
due to if I could nuclear charge that we
mentioned in the previous video right
the S orbitals have lower energy than
the P low which have lower energy and
lower energy that we absolutely have
orbital to the highest and energy and
that's because of the effective nuclear
charge differences which we talked about
in the previous video so now you'll
notice here that I didn't really put all
of the orbitals in this inner energy
diagram so the others are kind of listed
here so we go from one s we already
mentioned that we go from 1 s 2 to s
clicks in a different color let's do
this so 1 s then goes to 2 s then
there's two P then there's 3 s then
there's 3p then there's 4s and then
there's 3d and then what happens after
that well the order is actually shown
down here so we go from 1s2 2s2 2p2 3s2
3p2 4s 2 3 d 24 p 2 5's 24 d 2 5 p-6 s4
f 5 D 6 p-7 s 5f 67p so on so do we need
to know this order the answer is yes
it's just how we have to memorize it not
exactly there are ways to remember
remember this and we'll actually see
more about that later because this is
the order in which the orbitals are
actually filled with electrons okay so
that is that concept of that idea that
topic is called electron configurations
and that will be covered in the next
series so I hope that video was helpful
thank you for watching if you found that
video helpful don't forget to like
and subscribe and share with friends
thank you and happy studying